Hello Freak pitches.
You know,
one of my heroes who's building a health city in the Cayman Islands is named a
Devy shitty.
Uh,
he did create name.
Yeah.
He's a,
he's an Indian guy and he did amazing stuff with,
you know,
he'll offer Americans,
uh,
heart surgery for one 10th the price with the best doctors and that makes them
enough money where he can offer a medical insurance to rural Indians,
uh,
for 25 cents a month.
So he plays this kind of jurisdictional arbitrage.
So now he's moving,
uh,
to the Cayman Islands and building what are called health cities ready to catch
the wiving,
the rising wave of Americans who are going to be dissatisfied with their
healthcare and when a faster,
quicker and cheaper.
And we'll fly there.
And I,
I've been looking at him as a guy that seems like he understands what
seasteading would be.
He seems to understand the principles and he's applying them by using real
islands.
And I've always fantasized if I could talk to him and get him to like invest in
the cease dead.
And you know,
I almost peed my pants a few months ago where he was in the news and he said,
you know,
the best place to have a floating hospital would be on a ship,
off the coast of a major American city.
Given that we don't have that,
I'm going to build one in the Cayman Islands.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
there's so many people thinking along these lines.
Like if we could just,
we have innovations and technologies moving forward and we have regulatory
structures and government's holding it back and the world can't be held back.
The world has to move forward when you don't want to overthrow governments
that's violent.
You want to innovate and compete with an embarrassed governments the way you
know Singapore and Hong Kong and the island man have done.
Heck,
she was like that too.
I worked with him in Texas.
I mean this is,
I was getting high,
so 29 years ago,
30 you know,
wow.
And kiss something happened to him in seven 11 and he went on stage and adlibbed
about it to next night for tea.
And I'm going,
I'll never be that funny as long as I fucking live.
I'll never be that for,
why am I doing this?
We were at catch a rising star in New York one night.
So Brenner goes on and this is,
I mean they love Brenner was fucking bread or at the time.
Yeah,
cause he was a big act back then.
Big fucking act.
So ladies and John Deere Brenner kills the fucking audience.
Goes nuts.
Okay.
So does he set there one and Hicks goes on after him.
Hicks opens up with,
you know,
I was growing up and I used to watch comedy on TV and I'd watch Robert Klein and
David Brenner.
I'm thinking if these fucking guys can do with,
so can I,
that's his opening fucking joke.
Then he goes into that Nancy Reagan,
that anorexic Qantas Hall.
So people are running out like there was a fire.
I mean he just fucking cunt and mean it's comics and he gets off stage.
I swear to God,
he walked up to me,
he goes,
fuck what happened?
What went wrong?
Oh,
I don't know.
Maybe the anorexic conti trashing the guy,
that date is fucking loved and he was so fucking dark,
just dark,
just Wah.
You know what I mean?
It's just like if you listen to now,
you're going to have,
that's all right.
But this is fucking 30 years ago,
this is 30 years ago,
this shit was fucking dark.
You know,
Jenny will take a bit,
he would take a premise like you say,
and you know,
it could,
he could turn it into 20 fucking minutes.
He would bring shit out of like,
well,
how the fuck did he come up with that added that you're going,
what?
You know what I mean?
Uh,
but Hicks was so fucking dark and he just,
it,
we,
we're in fucking Texas.
This is true story.
So he,
his girlfriend just broke up with him.
He was going out with her forever.
So we're in a cab and he said to the cab driver,
I want to hooker in tech.
And we were in Lubbock in Lubbock.
It's a true story.
So the old man,
so I made me shivers just thinking about it.
So,
so the cab driver's said,
okay,
I'll take you to one plate on and you go to their house.
So I was just going to wait in the cab like so.
He wants to the first house and the lady opened the door and looked at him,
goes to a cops,
slammed the door,
excuse back into car
[inaudible]
but then it makes no sense,
don't Kevin,
I would take him to another place.
She opens the door and goes,
you're too young.
Slams the door,
gets in the car.
He goes,
I can't get fucking hookers me 10 minutes the next night.
Just brilliant fucking on hookers.
That won't fuck up
in local taxes.
Just fucking brilliant.
I'm going.
It's unbelievable how fucking good this guy is.
The
the amount of responsibility involved in influencing a young developing mind
can't be under overestimated due.
You have to overcome for remember when you were a kid?
Yeah,
I do like good ones.
Like late,
like the sun in the sky.
You can see any kind of see any star.
I can't see the other teachers in my head for the few good ones that I had.
Yeah.
What an incredibly,
they could all be like,
obviously it'd be great,
but I mean teach us.
Yeah.
Awesome responsibility.
I had some great ones.
I had a few great ones that were just really good people that were smart and
kind and they,
they,
they profoundly,
I had a science teacher in seventh grade that I had a discussion with him,
just me and him one day and I never forgot it.
And we were talking about space and he was a really interesting guy.
You know,
it was a bad neighborhood we lived in,
I lived in Jamaica plain,
which was like this um,
neighborhood in Boston just outside of um,
uh,
Boston.
It's just is a real shit neighborhood at the time.
It's become a little bit gentrified now,
but back then it was just really sketchy,
very poor kids.
And was a kid that was in my class.
I guess I was seventh grade eight went ninth is a highschool is eighth grade
cause it was right before high school and this kid was 17 years old and the
fucking eighth grade.
I mean,
it was crazy cause they were just,
there would be there for the beginning of the year and then they would drop out.
And uh,
this science teacher was,
you know,
in this shit school system,
but he was just genuinely kind,
curious patient man.
And he talked to me about space and,
and I'd never considered the idea that space is never ending.
And he was explaining the concept of infinity to me and that there truly is no
boundary.
And if you really any,
I remember he said,
do you ever really want to make your head hurt?
Just stare at the sky and try to wrap your head around the idea that it never
ends.
And we had this long conversation about it and Nick Inbetween classes one day,
not even a long,
you know,
10 minutes maybe,
but enough that I,
I thought about that for years to this day.
I remember that guy.
That's a great,
Richard Fiman was this a physicist?
A fantastic guy.
And uh,
he said,
told about his father that his,
you know,
he was pulling some wagon and he had balls in the wagon.
He said,
you know,
it's when you pull the wagon,
the ball stay for a bit,
and then they bump up and then you stop the wagon.
They keep going.
So he was talking about momentum and physics and all that.
And so like all kids,
he said,
well,
why,
why?
And then he got to a point with his father where he said,
well,
why?
And his father said that nobody knows.
Like,
why is there gravity?
I mean that nobody knows.
Yeah.
And uh,
I think those kinds of questions where you really stimulate your mind,
I think is a great idea.
I was telling my daughter a couple of,
I made me two months ago about a,
there's an old Spanish proverb that says,
Whoa,
um,
habits begin as cobwebs and end up has chains way easier to break in the
beginning than later off.
Right.
Way To put it.
It's a great way to put it.
Wow.
And,
uh,
anyway,
she just,
she just brought this up,
uh,
you know,
um,
that we were talking about someone she knew and,
and something that she didn't like that they did.
And she said,
yeah,
but that's still pretty much in the cob web phase,
so they can probably still change it at him.
She's like,
well,
I even,
I didn't remember.
She's like,
Oh yeah,
the cob webs and change things.
Like she really sunk in her and she's like five and she can remember those
things that can really take you through life and give you real clarity.
I think that stuff is great,
and I remember those people who gave me those important lessons as,
as a kid.